well a harrowing operation in New
Zealand is recovering the remains of
victims of Monday's deadly volcano
eruption newly released pictures show
teams in hazmat suits and gas masks
scouring the floor of the White Island
crater six bodies were removed yesterday
but two remain the death toll is now at
16 Ramey Inocencio is in New Zealand
where the danger on that island is clear
to see some families were able to
breathe a collective sigh of relief
after those six bodies were recovered
those were brought here to Auckland
Hospital but two others are still
missing and rescuers will have to return
that's despite warnings that the volcano
is still very volatile a team of elite
New Zealand soldiers raced to white
island on a dangerous mission to reunite
families with the remains of their loved
ones clad in yellow protective suits and
gas masks the eighth person squad spent
four hours searching the volcano for
victims the environment that those staff
encountered was unpredictable scientists
say the volcanic gas is being emitted on
the island are so toxic that a single
breath could be deadly there was of
course a huge amount of courage still
required to do what they did today
it looks pretty peaceful from this
distance but you can take a look at that
plume which indicates that still is a
very seismically active volcano the
recovery team had to cut their ground
search short reportedly because their
air supply was dwindling two bodies are
still missing
we do believe that at least one of them
is in the water
and the other one we are unsure Brenda
Inga Ronnie Gordon's nephew is believed
to be one of them he was such a joyful
I'm not the haughty fool so full of love
for everyone
24-year old - petty Maggie was a white
island tour guide do you think that the
New Zealand government officials should
have moved faster to get those loved
ones off of white island to be honest
they did the best they could
they were ensuring that everybody was
safe we would have rowed out there if we
couldn't
but the fact is it was too dangerous the
energy that you have is one of respects
and calm and thoughtfulness we move
forward with grave it's the only way to
move forward and authorities are
redeploying dive teams tomorrow to find
the final two in the hopes to reunite
them with their families
Michele Ramey and ensign Co and New
Zealand thank you